Use the given information to
make a logical conclusion,
if possible.
If a logical conclusion
is not possible,
choose "no logical
conclusion possible."
All right.
So let's see what they tell us.
So the statement is, if
I go to practice today,
then I will play in
the game tomorrow.
So this statement
is saying, look,
if I go to practice
today, then I'm
definitely going to play
in the game tomorrow.
And then they say, I will not
play in the game tomorrow.
Well, I just said that if
I go to practice today,
I'm going to play in that game.
And they just said, I'm
not playing in that game.
So I must not be going
to practice today.
Because if I went, I would play.
So I did not go to practice.
So let's do a couple
more of these.
OK, so the same instructions.
If William misses the bus, then
he will be late for school.
William is late for school.
So let's think about
this a little bit.
If William misses the bus, then
he will be late for school.
William is late for school.
So missing the bus
is one way that you
could be late for school.
But he might have
not missed the bus.
He might have caught the bus,
but then kind of sat in the bus
once he got to school.
So missing the bus
is one of the ways
that he could be
late for school.
But it's not the only way
he could be late for school.
They just say, if
he misses the bus,
then he is late for school.
Now, if they said, he
is not late for school,
then you know that he
didn't miss the bus.
Because if he did, he
would have been late.
But there's many ways to be
late, not just missing the bus.
So we don't know for a fact
that William definitely
missed the bus.
Let's do a few more of these.
If a ray bisects an angle, so
it splits that angle in two,
then it creates two
congruent angles, all right?
If there are two
congruent angles,
then the two angles
have the same measure.
All right.
So this one's a
little bit more hairy.
So let's see, if a
ray bisects an angle,
then it creates two
congruent angles.
Yep, OK, I can buy that.
In fact, that is
definitely true.
If there are two
congruent angles,
then the two angles
have the same measure.
OK, I can buy that, as well.
If a ray bisects an
angle, then the two angles
have the same measure.
So let's see.
So this first sentence says,
if a ray bisects an angle,
then it creates two
congruent angles.
But then the next one says, if
there are two congruent angles,
then the two angles
have the same measure.
So if a ray bisects
an angle, there's
two congruent angles, which
the next sentence tells us
that the two angles
have the same measure.
And that's the statement here.
If a ray bisects an
angle, then the two angles
have the same measure.
And you're going to say, wait,
wait, how is this different?
Look, in the first sentence, it
says the ray bisecting an angle
creates two congruent angles.
So we don't know yet what
congruent angle means.
The next sentence says, if
there are two congruent angles,
then the two angles
have the same measure.
So the second
sentence lets us know
that two congruent angles
must have the same measure.
So now, we can kind of merge
these two together to say,
if a ray bisects
an angle, then it
creates two angles that
have the same measure, which
is this choice right over here.